le système s'appelle VFR to tango Delta
allez Philip est le pont George Washington
à 1100 angle denté fin Delta
et le trafic étourdit bangla
pisserait l'hélicoptère en direction de l'ouest 800 sur le -
papa Romy êtes-vous prêt à aller à Kiev
notre prophète d'accord vous pouvez partir en
bravo  espace aérien contacté à propos de notre
un-un-neuf virgule cinq douzaines opéra
romeo merci de pimenter
c'est pour l'arbre juste un
citron de votre destination cher papa aime passer devant le
GW n'a pas entendu la transition de retour ou
quatre fois de plus
papa est ici  tu vas bien de 2007 ici euh
papa
et en quelque sorte perdre le pont par l'arrière
donc celui qui vient juste à l'arrière
peu importe juste demain ouais
le truc à propos de la circulation sur le bloc
rêve de la direction mm être un facteur
mm Sarah Papa trafic 12 o  'horloge ou 3
miles de la direction après 1300 faire
et je devrais être un
but bien